and we're live how are you sir hey I'm
great thanks for being here man I really
appreciate it it is the coolest thing
I've done really ever it's pretty cool
I watched your TED talk on what was the
word that used lesterland olestra yeah
and it felt hopeless like for people who
don't know what I'm talking about could
you just give like a brief synopsis of
the way you were describing how complete
completely rigged our election system is
and and what what it actually takes to
be elected and how much of the time they
spend is involved in raising money and
why yes so we've got a system where we
have a money primary and then we have a
regular election and in the money
primary to compete you gotta raise tons
of money to be able to fund your
campaign and when you raise that money
you raise it from a tiny tiny fraction
of the 1% so unless in the in the TED
talk about Leicester no I said you know
imagine a place called lesterland where
basically it's the Lester's who rule and
by the Lester's I mean the same
proportion of people named Lester as in
the United States right now there's
about a hundred and fifty thousand
Americans named Lester I'm one of them
but here we are
the Lester's so imaginal world ruled by
Lester land because that's essentially
the world we have because of the way we
fund our campaigns because there's about
a hundred and fifty
thousand men who give even just a
maximum contribution to one political
candidate if you ask who the number of
people who give the maximum contribution
over the course of a campaign meaning in
the primary and the general election
it's about twenty-two thousand Americans
in 2014 who gave them maximum
contribution to one political campaign
so what that means is it's a tiny tiny
fraction who are the most important
funders of political campaigns and
candidates for Congress and members of
Congress spent thirty to seventy percent
of their time sucking up to this tiny
tiny fraction and so is it any surprise
that you see Congress bending over
backwards to keep those guys happy
because they know without those people
they don't have a shot at getting back
into Congress and the way you were
describing it as when you're saying it
as lesterland it was like imagine if we
were this screwed up that was
essentially what you're saying yeah but
we're more screwed up in lesterland
yeah that was a disturbing video because
I was realized it was emerging as you
were speaking I was like wait a minute
is it that bad yeah
you know it's I actually since that
video have come to think it's even worse
so like a clarence land well it could be
worse because it's even smaller number
and if you look at the number of super
PAC donors you know the really critical
super PAC grown about a hundred people
who gave more than half of the super PAC
money in the last presidential election
you know a hundred you know so this is a
really tiny tiny number but what this
tiny number represents in the way we
fund campaigns is the extraordinary
inequality on that dimension right but
since since I was focused on the money
I've you know more recently but sorry I
think about the other screwed up to
mention something about gerrymandering
you know we gerrymander districts in
America so that about eighty five
percent of the House seats in the United
States Congress our safe seats which
means if you're a Republican in a safe
seat democratic district your views just
never matter
the Congress person because that vote of
a Republican will never determine who's
in Congress or a Democrat the safe seat
Republican district that's that's the
same okay but that doesn't mean those
Congress people are not afraid about
re-election of course they are afraid
about whether they'll be reelected but
they're afraid not of a Democrat running
against a Republican they're afraid of
an even more extreme Republican running
against the incumbent Republican so what
those incumbents in those safe seat
districts do is they obsess about what
the extremists in their own party cares
about so the extremists on the left and
the right have this ability to leverage
extraordinary influence inside of the
House of Representatives simply because
we've decided to gerrymander these
districts to create these safe seats so
those extremists are a kind of Lester's
too there are more of them you know it's
more democratic than lesterland but they
too have enormous influence over
ordinary people and most ordinary
people's views then to these Congress
people just don't matter that feels
hopeless for a dummy like me sitting on
the outside looking at this and like God
if this is this deeply entrenched with I
mean I guess it's not technically
corruption because it's all legal but
it's an entanglement with money and with
influence that that I mean how do you
one wind this yeah so that point is
really critical it's not technically
illegal hmm and what that means is the
people are engaged in this are not doing
wrong things they're just playing by the
rules all right they're playing with the
system it's just that the system has
become corrupted when did it start well
I think that the moment the United
States Congress begins to fall apart in
a really dramatic and interesting way is
when Newt Gingrich becomes Speaker of
the House so when the Republicans take
control of Congress in 95 it's the first
time the Republicans have taken control
of the House of Representatives in 40
years so the house becomes incredibly
competitive each election you know is up
for grabs who's going to
and for all the house so Gingrich turns
his members in the house into perpetual
fundraisers it's basically we got to
raise the money to defend ourselves the
next time around and then the Democrats
followed suit so the Democrats turned
their members into perpetual fundraisers
and they changed the rules about like
who gets to be chairmen of committees
it's no longer like who's the person
with the most experience or the most
insight increasingly becomes who raises
the most money and the Democratic Party
I know about the Democratic Party the
Republicans don't talk to me much but
the Democratic Party increasingly
changes its focus from what are the
policies that our members care about to
what are we going to do to make sure
that you as a member meet your
fundraising target and so from 95 until
today the institution becomes an
institution focused on the game of
getting reelected
I'm Jim Cooper a Democrat from Tennessee
who went to Congress first in like 1983
so he's been there for a long time
Cooper says Capitol Hill has become a
kind of farm League for K Street okay so
what do you mean by that is members go
there they learn how to raise money they
become focused obsessively on raising
money but one of the things that they're
really focused on it's how do they go
from Capitol Hill to becoming a lobbyist
because that's where the real money is
you know a member of Congress gets paid
about as much as the students I ate at
the Harvard Law School in their first
year as lawyers you know so to ordinary
Americans there's a lot of money but two
people on Capitol Hill doesn't seem like
a lot of money but then they go and
become a lobbyist they can make ten
times that as a lobbyist and so what
Cooper says is you have this institution
which has become so focused on the money
that it's it's just institution for
producing influence that can be sold and
first the congressmen are basically
sucking up so that people who want to
buy influence and then the congressmen
become the people buying influence
themselves because they're working as
lobbyists for these important interests
so they're in the rigged game they
understand how it gets rigged and then
they work to rig it yeah yeah they see
this is their their business it's their
honeypot yeah